[Música]
salud en directo américa de france 24 me
acompaña en el estudio más romeros a la
mar bienvenida ya estamos a martes así
que feliz mañana de martes en este día
que se conmemora la libertad de prensa
ojalá lo logremos más nosotros como
periodistas vamos a hablar de las
autoridades sanitarias que declararon un
nuevo brote de ébola en la república
democrática del congo que sabemos de
este caso más buenos días el rogle pues
mira sabemos que se trata del décimo
cuarto el número 14 brotes que se han
detectado en este país desde 1976 que
fue cuando se descubrió la enfermedad
del ébola también es el sexto desde 2018
por ahora sólo se han detectado dos
casos y la organización mundial de la
salud le explicaba cómo avanza así de
esta manera escuchamos lo
en fortín escribo expresión
desgraciadamente ambos pacientes han
muerto no ms está apoyando al gobierno
para reforzar las pruebas el rastreo de
contactos y las medidas de salud
públicas
reservas de vacunas del ébola en goma y
kinshasa ya se están transportando a
bandas k para que empiece la vacunación
estamos hablando de esta ciudad de
mbandaka que es una ciudad de un millón
de habitantes y pues sabemos que hay un
cierto riesgo de contagio que ahora sólo
haya dos casos porque estas dos personas
estuvieron en contacto con otras
personas mientras presentaban síntomas y
tardaron un poco en acudir a la
asistencia médica entonces pues
tendremos que ver qué alcance tiene
realmente el riesgo maric y qué tan
contagiosa es esta enfermedad pues es
muy contagiosa en caso de que entren en
contacto lo que llamamos fluidos
corporales que como hemos explicado en
otras ocasiones pueden ser por ejemplo
la sangre las mucosas las superficies
infectadas pero es que además de ser
altamente contagiosa es altamente letal
el ébola lo causa un virus en realidad
cuatro especies del mismo virus las
distintas
primero salta de animales a humanos
puede ser como explicábamos en contacto
por ejemplo con comida poco cocinada a
través de las heces en contacto
básicamente en zonas donde hay una
cierta estrechez con los animales
salvajes como sucede por ejemplo en
varias zonas de república democrática
del congo y después salta de humanos
entre humanos y así es como se sigue
contagiando a través como decíamos
mucosas sangres también de transmisión
sexual y a través de superficies de
objetos infectados la tasa media de
mortalidad ronda el 50 por ciento es
decir que la mitad de las personas que
se contagian están en riesgo de fallecer
a veces esa tasa ha sido más alta a
veces ha sido más baja depende un poco
de la situación epidemiológica y además
la gente pues no es contagiosa mientras
no tenga síntomas eso también es
importante
recordarlo al principio puede ser
difícil de distinguir de otras
enfermedades porque los primeros
síntomas son fiebre cansancio o dolor
muscular pero a medida que progresa se
va clarificando porque pasa un cuadro
donde hay vómitos diarreas y sobre todo
también hemorragia cuál es el origen más
de que se sigan presentando casos de
esta enfermedad de lula
es básicamente lo que sucede es que como
que está en contacto con los animales y
con en estas zonas naturales salta ese
virus de nuevo de animales a humanos no
es que se quede el virus en los humanos
y siga transmitiendo se si vemos por
ejemplo los brotes que hubo que
conocemos no por ejemplo en liberia
entre 2014 2016 también en guinea en
sierra leona causó más de 11.000 muertes
en ese caso y el siguiente brote también
en importancia fue en república
democrática del congo entre 2018 y 2020
con más de 2 mil 200 muertes entonces la
mayoría de estos como decíamos y lo que
ha sucedido en este caso también es un
nuevo salto lo que se dice en inglés
spielberg entre este virus que está en
los en el mundo animal y entre los
humanos que sucede que cada vez son más
frecuentes se descubrió en el 76 pero
cada vez están sucediendo con más
rapidez como hemos visto en república
democrática del congo por ejemplo y es
que puede suceder que con la
deforestación pues y el contacto a más
amplio se transmita más rápida bueno más
gracias entonces por toda la información
sobre estos casos de ébola estos
rebrotes en la república democrática del
congo pasamos ahora a ver nuestra
segunda entrevista del día con un
escritorio ecuatoriano le invito a que
la vea